a familiar ritual for em ep's ministers
of the current EU presidency knows Italy
pitching their pitch for the next six
months
Julian all Poletti employment and social
conditions Angelino Alfano immigration
and crime
Andrea Orlando justice I'm Mauricio
Lukie planes trains and things that move
mr. Poletti was absorbed by what absorbs
every European politician not to mention
millions of under 25s unemployment
Giovanni Charlie Charlie MEP is across
the spectrum warmed to his in
functions.php Secretariat on thisis not
really correlate with tribal Indian ants
in total in film's priority so Charlie
Marty Jeff Green is max to Italy
immigration has been and will continue
to be a big priority witness last year's
drowning of more than 350 boat refugees
off land producer and continuing deaths
at sea no system I hope AO community
asilo event impaired no fundamentally a
cooper que él era for cement oh the new
feature rope a OD sustainable asilo de
vente lemon toss truman Tolliver quest
EOB ATV his colleague Minister for
justice and Ray Orlando addressed
priorities and data protection and data
storage a predominant issue in the
coming months
next planes trains and boats transport
basically Italy's Transport Minister
Mauricio loopy outlined a packed agenda
to advance initiatives to improve air
transport and Europe's hopelessly
fractured rail network so plenty of work
for this presidency at a crucial time at
the start of a new Parliament
Tamm the italians will be able to get on
with it without too much scrutiny right
now MVPs leave this week for the summer
and won't be back till September